[Music]
we're running out of time you've seen
what's happening out there
[Music]
[Music]
I can handle zombies gonna show up
eventually that's what I'm afraid
it took you because you're immune to the
plague that's wiping out the human race
they think you're worth sacrificing to
find a cure but never stop until you
stop them the last city wicked slow base
of operations mr. meyen standard model
thanks for going three years we spent
behind walls trying to break out now
we're trying to break back in I guess
shotgun
the world is dying
if we find a cure that's the only way
all this was worth it
to aggress or you just host I did what I
thought was right
there's no guarantee we make you back
from this don't we stop this together as
well I'll end it that way too
you still care about it down here to
Miami
I'm gonna Cates believe the roundup
torture kill and how does it sound
it stops when we find a cure
[Music]
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
[Music]
please
somebody get this door open
any ideas
[Music]
baby
[Music]
okay
all right sorry
you sure about this not really
nice pep talk bloody inspire
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
so let's do a quick recap the last two
movies in 90 seconds or less ready the
bass one is about a group of boys who
are trapped in a designated area called
the glade surrounded by giant pools and
surviving on supply center by the boxes
once a month by a cryptic entity called
wicked his kid and in the maze of these
things called grievers once a month the
new boy comes this month it happens to
be this kid named Thomas any select few
runners are allowed beyond the walls but
Thomas breaks that role to save their
leader Alby and meet her by killing a
griever Thomas goes on Mission
Impossible style Bolton who saves the
prisoners suddenly a cow named Therese
that comes up in the books and
recognizes Thomas the girl comes out
she's like I know Thomas Thomas like I
know you and a struggle for power and
shoes when the second and come on Newt
designates Thomas a runner
Thomas is a revelation that wicked is
using them as a test subject and that he
used to actually work for them Boston's
and he leads a group to the Me's where
they uncover a secret laboratory and
then have dr. Ava page wickets director
of operations and a deadly virus called
the flare that it's ravaged the earth
none from Ava the experiment was a
success survivors are now entering phase
two the Scorch Trials
so in the scores Charles we are out in
this designated area called the Scorch
where this is fine is called the flare
and things turning in crags the reading
Gladers thomas neutrino teresa friar
Peter Winston taken to a wicked facility
run by mr. Jansen it looks like he's on
Game of Thrones who's supposed to
protecting them from Krank zombies
created by the flare virus but is
actually just a way for wicked to
continue their experiments before the
mucus and find a cure for themselves
Thomas meets a survivor heiress with the
croup they escape to the outside world
scourge where they befriend Brenda and
Jorge Jorge looks like he's on Breaking
Bad I'm sorry mama looks like you're
tagged none of the resistance called it
right on thank you
next thing you know a Paige comes in
Theresa betrays us because she called
Ava Paige on the cell phone was like a
cattle to mean always captured oh no
next thing you know they say Karis
Thomas and the remaining bladers out to
join force with a right arm rescue their
friends but topple wicked find that cure
[Music]
the last city wicked place of operations
we need to get him there we started this
together there's our island at that
whitey
there's no guarantee we make it back
from this the world is dying you still
care about another cure you can save
your friends or you can save us all
in cinemas January 18 we don't know how
not what if we were sent here for
reasons you're so close to the truth
don't you want to know why this all
happened
three years we spent behind walls trying
to break out and now we want to break
back in I guess shotgun
[Music]
you can't save everyone just
I can try
[Music]
well now how does it stop it stops when
we find a cure there is no cure
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
[Music]
which is the base of operations we need
to get him there three years we spent
behind wolves trying to break out and
now we want to break back in I get
shotgun
people busy
I can handle zombies he'll show up
eventually
you can't save everyone Thomas yes I'll
find out please run the deep cure in
cinemas January 18
[Music]